Diese entdeckung ist wirklich mehr als mysteriös denn die nun aufgespürte monster galaxie ist nicht nur
gigantisch groß sondern bildet auch eine enorme menge an neuen sternen und die
firma 4 milliarden lichtjahre entfernte galaxie gibt noch mehr rätsel auf und viele ihre eigenschaften sind einfach nicht
mit den gängigen modellen der evolution von galaxien zu erklären alle spannenden und prognosen facts zu dem kosmischen monster
jetzt bei pixum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Schon im jahr 2007 war die galaxie namens kosmos arzt tag 11 entdeckt worden allerdings
existieren bislang nur sehr unscharf wird bilder des himmels objektes es ist halt sehr weit
entfernt jetzt aber gibt es neue aufnahmen die mit den teleskopen des atacama large millimeter array
alma
entstanden sind und diese zeigen die äußerst
mysteriösen eigenschaften des kosmischen monsters mehr als eindeutig pro jahr entstehen in ihr beispielsweise
1000 mal mehr sterne als in der milchstraße dazu einer der beteiligten forscher
kenny kita duckie wir fanden heraus dass die sternentstehung in zwei großen gaswolken stattfindet die mehrere
tausend lichtjahre vom zentrum entfernt sind in den meisten fernen galaxien mit heftiger sternentstehung
bilden sich die sterne aber im zentrum dazu kommt eine weitere kuriosität die 12 4 milliarden lichtjahre entfernte galaxie
besitzt drei kerne um die schlingen sich eine reihe von spiralarmen
äußerst ungewöhnlich bei unserer milchstraße erstreckt sich die scheibe um einen einzelnen kern von dem auch die spiralarme
ausgeben bei der monster galaxie sind es stattdessen wie gesagt drei kerne alle sind jeweils von eigenen
stern reichen glasscheiben umgeben doch wie ist diese gigantische galaxie entstanden möglicherweise durch die verschmelzung mehrerer
sterneninsel das würde dann auch erklären warum die enthaltenen gaswolken so instabil sind denn wenn galaxien
zusammenstoßen wird das gas in kleine gebiete
zusammengepresst das wiederum lässt sich schwerkraft stark ansteigen was dann nicht nur den kollaps der gaswolken bedeutet sondern auch die zündung neuer stern
aktuell jedoch sei keine verschmelzung zu beobachten so das forschungsteam dennoch hoffen die wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler mit hilfe von alma
ähnliche galaxien beobachten zu können denn damit ließe sich dann langfristig die beziehung zwischen monster galaxien und galaxien
verschmelzungen erforschen nach analyse des forschungsteams ist das jetzt entdeckte
kosmische monster wohl in der ersten milliarde jahre nach dem urknall entstanden der ja vor 13,8 milliarden jahren stattfand umso ungewöhnlicher
dass die galaxie zitat eine massereiche und geordnete glasscheibe besitzt die regulär rotiert so die
studienautoren denn der großteil der galaxien im frühen universum sind strukturlos und klein
demnach hätte das autorenteam nach eigenen angaben eher
eine art kosmischen trümmerhaufen erwartet doch das forschungsteam hat auch eine erklärung für die merkwürdigen
charakteristika der monster galaxie die rasante sternen bildung beispielsweise
wird durch die gravitation erklärt dan materie wird durch die schwerkraft der galaxien nach innen gezogen
diese anziehungskraft kann durch die andere kraft die nach außen gerichtet ist nicht kompensiert werden die gaswolken fallen in sich zusammen
denn sie sind instabil und verdichten sich so entstehen die
keimzellen neuer sonnen dichte materie klumpen dennoch bleiben einige rätsel offen denn die gängigen modelle der evolution von
galaxien erklären weder die starke sternentstehung noch die gigantische ausdehnung auch die mysteriöse
drei kernstruktur ist noch ein ungelöstes rätsel
ja und wenn er zu den weiteren forschung zur monster galaxie und zu allen anderen themen kein video mehr verpassen wollt dann habe ich gleich
am ende des videos einen trick für euch jetzt aber unser hochgestecktes ziel
keine werbung mehr auf clixoom wir haben ja schon angefangen immer mehr videos sind werbefrei dank eurer hilfe
immer wenn wir entsprechend viele kanal mitglieder gewonnen haben schalten wir die werbung vor einem video ab also macht mit werdet mitglied hier
unter dem video draufklicken oder auf den link in der video beschreibung ihr bekommt noch exklusive extra videos live streams und noch ein paar weitere
privilegien
für einen kleinen beitrag und jetzt der trick wenn er immer garantiert über aktuelle videos informiert werden wollt dann hättet mich bei whatsapp nur da
bekommt ihr das aktuelle video deutlich vor allen anderen von mir persönlich auf ihr handy einfach hier draufklicken
und darunter geht es weiter dafür auch draufklicken mit dem video spektakuläre entdeckung galaxie ohne dunkle materie bis dann
bleibt